au large de points des monts sur la côte
nord l'émission scientifique
s'enchaînent sur le Coriolis 2
les chercheurs ont les yeux rivés sur
d’extraordinaire canyon sous-marin d'une
longueur de 4 km d'une profondeur allant
jusqu'à 300 mètres sous l'eau donc les
grandes sessions un peu comme on
s'imagine le Grand Canyon aux États-Unis
on voit la même chose dans le fond de
l'eau certains plus petits certains plus
gros ces canyon sont une sorte
d'autoroute dans laquelle les sédiments
sont transportés vers les profondeurs du
fleuve
des avalanches de sédiments peuvent s'y
déclencher tout emporter sur leur
passage y compris des câbles sous-marins
et donc si ces infrastructures-là sont
brisées par ces arranges de ces
éléments-là ou par sédimentaires là mais
ça peut affecter notre vie de tous les
jours
des scientifiques des universités
lavalent du Québec à Rimouski tente de
mieux comprendre la dynamique de ces
sédiments dans le temps mais dans le
fond marin l'eau et les courants ont la
capacité de transporter des sédiments de
façon plus intense et beaucoup plus
active et beaucoup plus sur de grandes
distances quand le lieu terrestre un
point de démon on soupçonne que les
vents violents agissent comme
déclencheur des avalanches de sédiments
ça prend vraiment des tempêtes assez
importantes qui augmentent la hauteur
des vagues on pense que ça prend aussi
de marée basse parce que plus madame
Marie est basse plus l'impact des vagues
va affecter le fond marin par rapport à
une marée haute ce brassage intense est
profondé sédiments pourrait à son tour
remettre en suspension des organismes
potentiellement toxiques qui dorment au
fond de l'eau
étudie le phénomène et si les conditions
redeviennent profites si la cellule a
accès a suffisamment d'oxygène et que la
cellule va sortir de son enveloppe et va
pouvoir continuer son cycle de vie va
pouvoir se diviser pour les faire dans
la colonne d'eau pour l'instant les
canyones ou large de points formidable
laboratoire naturel un site qui permet
de mieux comprendre des transformations
qui surviennent dans le fond marin ici
André Bernard Radio-Canada Montréal